I have no problem at all with charter
schools functioning as a poor man's
private school are we saying that if you
are a poor black and brown kid it's a
problem that you should have disruptive
free studious high quality school why is
that unfair our charter schools guilty
of weeding out difficult kids and is
this undermining their overall mission
in October the New York Times broke the
story that a principal at the charter
school networks Success Academy target a
group of students to be pushed out of
his school maintaining a secret got to
go list the controversy has spurred an
ongoing debate and to discuss it I'm
joined by Robert Pandey CEO vice
president at the Education think-tank -
Thomas Fordham foundation and a former
public school teacher in the Bronx
Robert thanks for talking to us things
are headed it let's start with some
background on success Academy what is
Success Academy and what does it do to
get so much positive and negative
attention what a great question how much
time do we have is good because we could
take all day answering just that
question success is a successful charter
school or CMO a charter management
organization a lot of us in the Charter
world look at them I always make the
joke like the scene in what heroine
Harry Met Sally you know I'll have what
they're having because they are just
doing so amazingly well relative to
other charters can you quantify you know
how well they're doing relative to
charters as well as relative to general
I mean I don't have the data at arm's
length obviously but I remember a year
ago something on the order of 80 percent
of their third and fourth graders we're
getting not just threes which are
proficient but fours above proficient on
the tougher Common Core math tests you
know I think five hundred some-odd kids
throughout the city I wouldn't have
guessed there were five hundred
low-income black and Hispanic fours in
New York City let alone in one CMO so I
mean those are just incredible
incredible numbers and their literacy
scores are not as I popping but still
quite good in other words they are
lapping the field so to speak talk a
little bit about the controversy over
the got to go list describe the broader
allegations and let you know what's
going on yeah I mean I think there's
it's a two-part answer one charter
schools in general at least in New York
City are commonly accused of what they
call creaming taking the best kids the
brightest kids
and not educating the so-called harder
to teach so that that that umbrella goes
over the discussion of charters more
broadly in the case of Eva Moskowitz and
Success Academy because they've had
these incredible results everybody's
been looking for the how does she do it
answer and part of the answer people
like to believe people who don't like
what she's doing is that they
aggressively counsel out as they say
kids who are either difficult to teach
who are disruptive etc and only keep not
just the Queen but the cream of the
cream and that's how they're getting so
to charter schools cream it's
complicated I mean first of all look I
don't you know I'm a charter advocate I
work in a charter school but I'm
clear-eyed about these things I think
it's naive for charter advocates to say
no we don't clean well what do you mean
by cleaning if you ask is is there a
general sense in Harlem and the South
Bronx and places where you find these
Success Academy schools and others that
this is where you go if your kid is you
know if you're a low-income parent you
want your kid to go to Harvard or Yale
no I don't think that's that's it at all
so I don't that said there's a certain
self selection bias just by dint of the
fact if you are an engaged parent and
and you're seeking out a better option
for your kid you're automatically one
step ahead of the vast unwashed so to
speak but now what do we mean when we
see creaming are they are they
aggressively pushing kids out who are
difficult to teach I see no evidence
that they are on the other hand I see no
evidence that they're not if these
stories are true about you know got to
go less or your counseling it's just a
lot more subtle than be open but do they
call into question Success Academy or
other charter schools success are you a
fan of success or not I would argue not
like I've gotten myself in a little bit
of trouble with this because I
personally and I'm speaking just for
myself have no problem at all with
charter schools functioning as what I
would describe is a poor man's private
school you know full disclosure I was a
public school teacher I send my daughter
to a private school I went to school in
a decent suburban school where we never
had to deal with problems of the hardest
to teach of the disruptive kid where do
these kids go we say are we to believe
that they don't exist in in better zip
codes
one of the things and again just
speaking for myself that kind of bothers
me about this argument in general is why
we only upset let's just assume for a
second that it's true okay so and I'd
again have no reason to believe that it
is but let's just say the worst
allegations are true
she is counseling out the hardest to
teach she's creating this poor man's
private school why is that a bad thing
in other words are we are we saying that
if you are a poor black and brown kid
it's a problem that you should have what
a what an affluent kid in the Upper East
Side has a disruptive free studious high
quality school why is that unfair well
let those kids talk about that because
the education historian and arguably the
most prominent charter school critic
around Diane Ravich read the following
in response to this controversy about
Success Academy and I quote public
schools are supposed to work for all
kids granted there are magnet schools
and special schools men there are
supposed to be public schools where no
one has turned away
no one has canceled out nameless so okay
so that's name one a few months ago I
wrote a column for US news about this
and I wrote about a kid who had been
facing what seemed to be the exact same
circumstances that the New York Times
highlighted for some of these that the
the got to go kids and it turns out the
kid was in the leafy suburban community
of Irvington New York and suddenly was
his parents felt harassed and they ended
up moving to it to a school system
nearby where he was he was able to be
taken care of another data point that
came up in this piece
I think was Montclair New Jersey is
spending something like five million
dollars a year on out of district
placements for 70 some-odd kids now I
you know because of privacy rules it's
impossible to know the circumstance of
each of those kids do they have a
condition that really can't be met by
the the Montclair school system but the
bottom line is kids in Montclair don't
have to deal with the with the
disruptive kids etcetera yeah in the US
News column that you read the subhead is
why is it unfair to give poor families
the studious disruption free schools the
rich take for granted that zigzag right
so I'm not taking a side here I want to
be clear on that but I just want to be
clear eyed about it I just don't buy
this idea that that public schools take
everybody
you know then this raises a question you
know a charter network that with the
size and resources of Success Academy
shouldn't they have the capacity to
cater to all children without dumping
you know problem students back into the
day that's what they're doing yeah I
think I think that's a fair thing to say
and and let me put in a plug for
democracy prep where I work we've
actually created a program called
pathways where we educate special ed
kids from throughout the network in a
single what we would call it district 75
so the situation in New York City so
what do you mean by the district 75 is a
special education district within the
New York City school system one of the
criticisms and charters is though you
don't work with kids with with IEP s and
special education well that's not true
of all of us some of us do yeah but
again I want to be clear about this the
spirit of what charters do that should
be their choice I would argue in other
words should as soon as you duplicate
the conditions of the public school
system you're going to duplicate their
results so while on the one hand I'm not
very fond of charter advocates saying
things like oh we take all the same
children we get all the we get better
results yeah you have a different set of
rules let's be candid about that having
said that what I want to impose a set of
rules on success not necessarily I think
it's important to let charter schools do
what charter schools do well having said
that I think a lot of the conflict is
when there is this we say one thing and
we do another look the other issue in a
sense our charters may be fulfilling a
role that
parochial schools used to you know so
it's like you scratch you know I mean
parochial schools in most cities started
losing population around 1960 when
populations been that but they were
cheap relative to private schools
private academies and you would see you
know ethnics well you know black and
white ethnic sending their kids have
regardless of religion yeah and I think
if we're fair about this I think a lot
of the so-called high-performing
no-excuses charter schools are a
cut-rate version of what Catholic
schools the role that they used to play
in our inner cities they're good I think
I'm not sure they're as good as those
those Catholic schools are or used to be
but look the other issue that we're not
talking about here is is the issue of
school tone so whether whether or not a
kid is meet the test for giftedness
almost doesn't matter
you have to create the conditions that
allow productive learning to go on you
have to valorize normalize you know a
studious environment if you've ever been
to a Success Academy they do that
exceptionally well and I say this having
been a fifth grade publican teacher for
many many years I could have gotten so
much more done if I didn't spend all of
my time not just managing three or four
disruptive kids but having to frankly
cater to them and ignoring the rest all
right well we will leave it there thank
you so much we've been talking with
Robert Pandey CEO he's the vice
president at the education think-tank
the Thomas Fordham foundation and a
former public school teacher in the
Bronx Robert thanks for talking thanks
for having me for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie